can we talk about kovid first and
foremost we've got this rule of six
coming into force
uh on monday there are real concerns out
there about this how it how it is
managed how it's enforced and and also
why
children under 12 are not exempt from
this rule of six in
in england yes you're absolutely right
there are um
there are new restrictions on uh social
gatherings that come into force on
monday
the rule of six as you as you quite
rightly point out no more than six
people
meeting together inside or out
one of the reasons for the rule is it's
a simple measure that commands public
confidence
that's required because we've seen as as
you've been reporting
an increase in the rate of infection
we've seen the infection uh rate
increase in france and spain and other
european countries
and as a result more people in hospital
and tragically more people dying and
more people suffering
you know really bad uh health outcomes
so that's why we're taking these steps
but it's it's not simple is it i mean
this is this is this is part of the
concern
that these these new rules are confusing
not only this
but then of course you've got slightly
different rules uh in england because
those under 12 are included in the six
where they're not in other parts
of the uk there's a big question about
as to whether you can sort of still go
out
and eat and how you can mingle in
restaurants and bars and all this sort
of scenario i mean
it is a confusing situation isn't it
i don't think so um i i do recognize
that um there are lots of questions out
there
um one of the purposes of you know a
conversation like this is to try to
reinforce
what i think is a a pretty
straightforward message
uh one of the reasons why you've chosen
um uh the rule of six
is it's well understood um and as i
mentioned earlier it commands public
confidence the public understand and
recognize that
indoors or outdoors six people is the
maximum they know
that it's because of uh uh social
gatherings or household gatherings
uh that have had more people than that
or where people for for whatever reason
uh have been mixing in a way that uh uh
contributes to the spread of the virus
um that we all need to exercise a
greater degree of self-discipline
so that rule i think is clear
of course scotland and wales do their
own things that's that's devolution
um but for for everyone in england um i
think that the principle is absolutely
crystal clear
and alongside that does the public
health uh message
hands face space again well understood
wash your hands regularly where face
coverings
and maintain social distance well i mean
you say it's straightforward in order to
preserve
life we have to kill the country if we
kill the country we have no life it's a
catch-22
that is why the messaging is so
confusing and why
people are so confused other words of
your wife in the mail on wednesday
well i love my wife i mean she's a
brilliant columnist um but
when it comes to government policy here
i think that the really important thing
to bear in mind
is that we're stressing the importance
of the economy
and education and we're saying that
people should be at work in covered
secure workplaces children
should be at school learning in a
covered secure environment
but when it comes to uh socializing
social mixing which inevitably involves
uh
or increases the risk of people from
different households
mixing and therefore increases the risk
of the virus spreading then there needs
to be an element of self-discipline and
that element of self-discipline
comes through recognizing the rule of
six and as i say it commands public
confidence
and therefore when you have a situation
as grave as the one that we face
having a policy that the public feel uh
is right and proportionate
and uh the appropriate answer um i think
uh that's a good thing
i mean look i mean i i don't think
anyone can actually
stand up straight and say there is a
very clear solution to how to deal with
this because
quite obviously there isn't but when
we're in this situation we've got some
pretty severe local lockdowns
coming into we're in force already some
more coming into force
on tuesday when the r rate we're told is
is sort of
1.2 and in some places possibly 1.7 and
hitting a critical level
you can understand why people are saying
is now actually the time to be sending
children back to school is that safe and
sensible
is it right that students are going back
to university
is this all going to bring about the the
the
major second wave that people are so
concerned about
it is absolutely right for children to
be back at school um and it is safe and
it is sensible
um and it's absolutely right for people
to be at work and
uh employers and trade unions and the
government to work together in order to
make sure
that there are clear rules um which you
know broadcasters like sky and others
follow
in order to ensure that we are safe at
work
but as we do there are additional risks
of the virus spreading
it seems as though the greatest risks
come from social interaction outside the
workplace
or outside schools we want to make sure
that people can still
see those they love but do so in a way
which is
consistent with limiting the spread of
the virus that's why we've got the rule
of six
that's why we've gone for a measure
which is clear and straightforward and
which as i say
commands public confidence it's part of
the issue though that you know
it is a bit of a pandora's box and the
lid has been opened on easing lock down
i mean for a few weeks now
and as a result of that people have
jumped at the chance to get out people
you know social you only have to go to
any town centre to see that social
distancing
has pretty much gone out the window now
it's very very hard to claw that back
unless you go
for a full lockdown isn't it
and we don't need to have a full
lockdown what we can have and what we
have had
are in those specific parts of the
country where we've seen an increase in
the virus
a a set of localized lockdown measures
prime minister was always clear
that in the battle against the virus
that we would see flare-ups and that we
would need
both uh those local lockdown measures
and broader
vigilance as well and one of the reasons
that we have the rule of six is because
as we've learned more about how the
virus operates we know that we can make
certain environments
safer there are other environments where
risks remain
and therefore we need to have
restrictions in order to police the
spread of infection
um in those settings um let's talk about
brexit if we can
you know it's it's it's been a while
need to get ourselves back into
brexit gear don't we what what is going
on
what what is the concern of the
government
over the withdrawal agreement that was
that was heralded
by the prime minister when it was put
through
well we're committed to implementing the
withdrawal agreement
we left the eu as everyone knows on the
31st of january um
the prime minister got brexit done we're
now in a different stage we're talking
about
our free trade agreement with the eu um
one of the things however though is that
as those talks have gone
on there are things that the eu should
have been doing which should be
committed to do
in order to make sure that we could have
the free flow of uh
food into the eu subject certain checks
um
in due course um the eu haven't been
keeping their signs of the bargain on
that question
and that raises doubts and concerns more
broadly
yeah presumably you have all you know in
government
you have fully read the withdrawal
agreement
uh yes uh one of the things about
the withdrawal agreement is that uh we
it was negotiated after
uh months of hard work and we are
implementing it
and we're implementing the northern
ireland protocol as well um
i've been spending uh or rather the
government department which i'm i'm
you know leading at the moment has been
spending hundreds of millions of pounds
in northern ireland making sure
that we implement it so that we can both
protect northern ireland's position
within the uk
but also help the eu by making sure that
we help protect their single market as
well
but i mean you can understand all the
confusion flying about
around all of this can't you i mean when
the withdrawal agreement was
was introduced and put forward obviously
the dup were very happy they were saying
it was putting a border down the irish
sea i mean that term was
discussed an awful lot you said in an
article in the belfast telegraph when
you were
at the ulster carpets factory i don't
accept the argument
that there will be a border down the
irish sea
and now the prime minister is turning
around and in in the zoom call with
conservative mps last night saying the
concern is
there is going to be a border down the
irish sea now if you didn't see that one
coming
six months ago 10 months ago
what were you looking at
well i was looking at the detail of the
protocol i'm a member of something
called the joint committee
um that means that people from the uk
government and the eu government get
together
in order to make sure that we can
implement the northern ireland protocol
appropriately uh it's a complicated
document as
as you um alluded to earlier uh so when
it comes to making sure that we have the
correct sanitary and phyto-sanitary
regime or
the correct approach towards uh i.t for
uh vhe collection in northern ireland
uh it's not the sort of stuff that i
think most people would regard as
uh perfect uh beach reading but it's
important that we do
implement it and we've been working well
to implement it however
but you should read that you should have
read that a year ago shouldn't you
the best part of a year ago uh i did
but one of the other things that i
should say is that again there's
something called
um a group of things called autonomous
processes these things that the eu
promised committed in the withdrawal
agreement to uh to get done quickly
um uh we haven't seen that progress
there uh
that has given rise to understandable
concern on the part of the prime
minister and me
uh that the uh the eu is not fulfilling
its side of the bargain
now we want a deal uh we hope that we
will get a free trade agreement
between the uk and the eu i think it's
in everyone's interests
but we've got to make sure that we have
an insurance policy if the eu aren't as
cooperative as we as we hope they will
this does break though dude i mean you
accept do you as as
the northern ireland secretary said in
the commons that this this does
in effect break international law if you
get this through
no the the the uh lord chancellor
forgive me forgive me but brendan lewis
was wrong was he
um again uh as i mentioned earlier these
are uh complicated issues i'm not trying
to
um uh run away from the complexity of
them i'm trying to
uh with your help of course um uh run
through all of these issues and
the legal position was made clear by the
attorney general um
uh we're operating within the rule of
law
uh it is the case however that we do
need to take
insurance policies um we hope that we
don't need to
uh implement uh the provisions that
exist within the uk internal market bill
but why are we bringing this bill
forward because it is
part of implementing the withdrawal
agreement and the northern ireland
protocol
it's part of making sure that we can
continue to have unfettered access
for goods from northern ireland from
businesses in northern ireland so they
can continue to benefit from being part
of the united kingdom
well i mean what one of the most
euroskeptic
members of parliament over the last
number of decades now in the house of
lords former leader of the conservative
party michael howard
i mean you know he wants to get out the
eu he wants to get out as quickly as
possible
he says this is a terrible idea
um well the house of lords debate that
occurred last week
was replied to by my my friend richard
keane he's one of the
the law officer team i mentioned the law
chancellor and the attorney general
earlier
their top government lawyers and um in
that debate uh
uh richard keane made clear that we were
operating within the rule of law
then why did brendan lewis say what he
said in the house
uh again one of the things about this
particular debate is that you need to
look at
all of the elements and balance and uh
the attorney general made clear that we
were operating
within the rule of law and one of the
reasons why we're taking forward this
legislation
is to make sure that we have uh the you
know the legal underpinnings for our
internal markets so that we can continue
to have
um uh goods from northern ireland uh on
sale in england wales and scotland
without any impediments and and that's
not only something to which we were
committed in our manifesto
it's also something that the eu are
committed to when they signed the
protocol
there are a lot of people asking as
quite what this is all about
in the sense of you know it it looks at
the moment i know things can change but
it looks very unlikely
that you would get this through the
house of lords even if you get it
through the house of commons which of
course is more likely with your majority
the prime minister said last night to
your colleagues
the bill is coming for its second
reading on monday i hope you will give
it overwhelming support
help us to support our negotiators this
is what the bill
is all about i mean is this basically a
negotiating tactic to try to get a free
trade deal are you playing hardball with
the eu
no no i mean it was exactly what it is
those are the words of the prime
minister this help us support our
negotiators when you know you're not
going to get it through the house of
lords
well again uh the the question contained
a number of assumptions
uh uh i think it's important to stress
that uh this bill
i think commands confidence from not
just conservatives but other people who
are committed to making sure that the
united kingdom
uh uh its security its economy uh its
future
is protected um and the purpose of this
bill is explicitly that and it's also
the case
that the purpose of uh the bill is to
make sure that the northern ireland
protocol
is implemented of course we want a free
trade deal that's why we're supporting
uh our excellent negotiating team david
frost in in
seeking to achieve that goal uh but i'm
confident that this legislation uh
when it's introduced into parliament
people will see exactly why we need it
it causes an awful lot of bad faith
doesn't it i mean the eu threatening to
sue us
at this stage this causes an awful lot
of bad faith at a very delicate time in
negotiations
no again i think uh only yesterday uh we
had a new free trade agreement with
japan my brilliant colleague list trust
has negotiated this deal
it gives us a better deal with japan
than we had in the eu the world's third
largest economy and our own the fifth
largest economy
in this new free trade agreement um if
it was the case that uh
you know uh uh we were having trouble
abroad um then we wouldn't be having a
this new deal with japan
well you you can't tie the two together
i mean
the the fact that we are getting these
deals and obviously a lot of people are
welcoming
the deal with japan but i mean that that
doesn't play into what's happening with
the eu which is still obviously a
crucial market for us moving forward
yep but i think you can i think that
you know one of the arguments uh is by
your uh
your actions some people have said oh
you know you're making more difficult to
secure agreements with other countries
well we've just secured an agreement
with japan some people say
oh well outside the uh uh eu you won't
be able to get better
uh terms for the uk we just have um and
uh and some people say oh there's no
link between the two well i think
actually uh britain concluding free
trade agreements with other countries
shows that um we should be able to
secure a free trade agreement with the
eu
because after all the deal that we're
asking for with the eu is is about the
same as the deal that they had with
canada
we've been in the eu for more than 40
years we've been paying in all the time
that we've been there
we've been following eu rules we've been
showing solidarity with our european
friends
and we're not asking for anything
special we're just asking for the same
deal that they've given
to canada so again it seems to me that
we've been reasonable
and again if one takes a step back it's
understandable that people
you know uh in the westminster bubble
think oh you know what's happening here
in the house of lords when this lord
said this or this lord said that
take a couple of steps back the british
people voted to leave the european union
the british people
want us to secure a deal with uh europe
which means that we can trade
but govern ourselves but we also know i
mean
we've heard it time and time again how
important the u.s
market is going to be for us moving
forward
if there is a democrat in the white
house
uh well from from january next year
which you know is
certainly a strong possibility nancy
pelosi the the the speaker of the house
there has said
the way that the government is behaving
on the withdrawal agreement and trying
to change that now in retrospect
is going to put us at the bottom of the
list as far as america is concerned
um it is the case that understandably
there are lots of american politicians
who are committed as i am
uh to implementing the uh the northern
ireland protocol and underpinning the
the good friday
agreement um i'm confident that uh
we will be able to conclude a deal with
europe
we'll be able to demonstrate uh to
everyone our continuing commitment
uh to the good friday agreement i think
i mentioned earlier that we're spending
hundreds of millions of pounds in order
to do so
and i think that we will continue to
have uh whichever great americans in the
white house
a strong relationship with the u.s
economic and security relationship